[موسيقى]
كان المنظر
كارثه يعني
عدد
الشهداء لا يعد ولا يحصى يعني شفت شيء انا
بعمري ما شفته شبهته انا بيوم القيامه
العالم بالشوارع الاطفال عم ترقد النساء
من دون غطاء على راسها
[موسيقى]
سامحني كمشفى اقرب شيء على البناء اللي
وقع على الكاريس اللي صارت فاكثر العالم
صارت عندنا يعني جرحى نساء حوامل
اطفال واهلتي كانت انه انا بدي جثه
الشريان ستوباتي اذا في نبض فانا بدي بدي
اساعده عشان يعيش امام الاطفال اكثر الشي
ما كنت يعني كنت عادي تماما
[موسيقى]
يعني امكانياتنا كانت محدوده نحن ما في
عنا شي يكفي يعني
لكارسه باكملها يعني نحن حاولنا قدر
الامكان نغطي هذا الشيء الحرب خزنتنا
كل الدنيا خذلتنا ما حدا اجا انقذ كان
الدفاع المدني بالخط الاول
ما حدا اجانا من برا فخلاص وقفت وقف الصوت
الاصوات اللي نزلنا نسمعه تحت الانقاض لحد
هلا في عالم تحت الانقاض يعني بسبب قله
الامكانيات والاليات
[موسيقى]
امنيتي انه هالاطفال اللي تضررت ترجع مثل
ما كانت هالبناء اللي نزل يرجع مثل ما كان
بدنا الامان اول شيء
انه يا ريت ما بقى حدا يضل يخزنا لانه نحن
نحن كسوريين تعذبنا كتير كتير بما حرب
زلازل فيضانات
وين بدنا نروح بعدين
[موسيقى]